if you're looking for a guy or a woman a
person that I could identify right now
on the national political answer who can
handle China who can handle Russia who
can handle all the issues who who
doesn't need to be brought up to speed
who's smart Tulsa gabbard do you think
no God no no no no she is listen that
that woman should not be allowed to wear
a uniform whoa whoa okay all right
there's a fundamental neither of you
served no he did he did right so then
you understand you don't do politics in
uniform she's going on social media and
her Colonel's uniform and doing politics
that's a big No-No I'm talking about
everyone's done it I get what you're
saying all these guys do and she was an
Assad apologist I will never she she no
when you go and you meet with that that
man dropped Barrel bombs on children she
dropped Barrel bombs on children they
dropped chlorine gas on kids no no no no
no no no no no
she does not get in a pass she's the
only American official in seven years
who stood with that son of a [ __ ]
if you want to have talk about values
right do we stand for something we don't
go and stand next to Assad and he say
he's a good man trying to do right would
you would you would you agree to do a
sit down with the Tulsi and you only if
I could spit in her face
wow I can't stand her I think she is
well that that's that's not gonna work I
think I think she is I think she is a a
complete and and total disappointment
she is she is derelict in her Duty she
is engaged in conduct Unbecoming
Behavior she ought to be court-martialed
for what she's done in uniform it's kind
of fortunate you feel that way somebody
conduct Unbecoming she got into a
uniform and went on so let me make a
different question let me ask a
different question the easiest charge to
bring up by the way as a commander if I
was her commander I'd bring her up on
conduct I'm becoming well maybe that's
what we talk about next time Tulsi Gabba
we put a glass into you guys and and uh
do you really know Chelsea of course if
you can get me in a room with Tulsi I
will not spit on her but you got to be
respectful bro I would be respectful of
her but she needs because she by the way
here's one thing about Tulsi she's gonna
see this and she's gonna say something
if she responds she is she is if you
want to have an opinion take off your
uniform I'm serious you you see this I
don't know what camera are I looking at
take off your uniform honestly he's a
gangster take off your uniform I'm
saying this to you as one fellow officer
or another I'm not sitting here doing
this in uniform right now right take off
your uniform if you want to continue
have an opinion you swore an oath like
the rest of us how dare you that's why
and and by the way apologize for meeting
Assad you met with a war criminal it's
like standing next to Hitler and being
proud of it you've seen Tulsi in a
bikini she looks pretty good when she
takes off her uniform listen Tulsi is
somebody that makes a lot of sense and
has a lot of loyal followers so it's
going to be interesting to see what
happens there so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]